[Musique]
elle avait à peine 20 ans elle
s'appelait anne marie lemay barbara
daigneault hélène collègues ou geneviève
bergeron certaines rêvait d'ouvrir leur
propre firme de génie d'autres voulaient
protéger l'environnement
quatorze femmes qui avait la vie devant
elle mais par un après midi glacial de
décembre
tout s'est brutalement arrêtée on se
tape juste ranquet qui avait été arrêté
dans la revendication dans leurs rêves
comme ça que j'ai le goût de montrer que
non il n'y aura pas n'y a eu ni heurts
peu fait peur aux filles on va continuer
dans les généraux viviano b à 24 ans
l'âge qu'avaient les victimes à l'époque
diplômé de polytechnique en génie
mécanique elle mène des recherches dans
le domaine de l'énergie
ses ambitions faciliter le passage aux
énergies vertes dans tout le nord-est du
continent
j'ai grandi en vouloir en voulant faire
une différence plus pour les changements
climatiques
c'est une grosse ambition mais elle fait
vraiment fait humanime liane brune steen
poursuit de son côté un doctorat au
prestigieux et mighty ce travail en
intelligence artificielle développe des
processeurs puis et efficace en termes
de consommation d'énergie et dit s ces
recherches vont permettre de réduire la
consommation énergétique des immenses
serveurs informatiques qui produisent
plus de co2 que l'industrie aéronautique
ça pourrait durer des gaz à effet serre
mais aussi ouvrir comme de nouvelles
applications pour l'intelligence
artificielle qui était comme par
accessible avant parce qu'on n'avait pas
assez de puissance des cas qu'elle vient
bunting viviane aubin n'était pas né le
jour de la tuerie mais elles tiennent à
honorer la mémoire de leurs quatorze
concerts car elles aussi étaient toutes
destinées un brillant avenir tué parce
qu'elles étaient des femmes
ces cercueils
c'est un moment d'extrême tristesse pour
liam byrne steen la tragédie de
polytechnique demeure l'incarnation de
l'antiféminisme ça me donne l'espoir en
fait que liane puisse nommer
l'arraisonnement comme ça parce que ça
dit qu'on est en train d'apprendre
nathalie provost a été gravement blessé
le jour des fusillades
elle a été atteint de plusieurs balles
ce qui est jeune fille de québec qui
pensaient aller en génie je vous demande
d'envisager cette possibilité de
carrière là et continue trente ans plus
tard à prendre la parole pour qu'on
n'oublie jamais le massacre de
polytechnique
c'est important pour que dans trente ans
encore on soit encore capable de dire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé nathalie
provost est aussi la marraine de l'ordre
de la rose blanche créé en mémoire des
victimes
pour qu'on se rappelle que derrière ces
quatorze femmes l'europe sont décédées
et avait 14 avenir brillant
cette bourse d'excellence et remises à
des femmes qui s'illustre dans le
domaine du génie je m'appliquerai à les
honorer en devenant une ingénieure
féministe impliqué forte et sensible
viviane aubin a décroché cette
récompense en 2018 pouvait être à la
hauteur de ce prix le de porter les
rêves les ambitions de ses filets qui
ont été arrêtés s'est abruptement si
violemment
yann burstyn a été décoré de l'ordre en
c'était vraiment un grand honneur je
trouve que ça amène ici une
responsabilité dans le sens très honoré
la mémoire des victimes d'être un bon
modèle pour les femmes qui pouvaient
aller en sciences à polytechnique la
professeur caroline boudou a su inspirer
diane donc songer de norman en plus
patent patients et respire encore
aujourd'hui les exemples féminin restera
dans le monde des sciences
il faut vraiment créer des modèles donc
il ya des femmes qui malgré ce qui est
arrivé ont réussi à persévérer et
quelques zones sont devenus des modèles
pour les prochaines pour moi c'est ça
c'est vraiment décidé d'améliorer la
société démontré que entre autres oui
les femmes on est capable de faire ce
genre de différence le fion de tout à
fait notre place en chine et de
construire le monde auquel rêvait les
quatorze femmes victimes de
polytechnique
un classement